I'm so excited to have you on the show
grace I have been watching your videos
recently and it's so cool to be sat with
two powerful beautiful incredible
intelligent successful women so thanks
for coming sure you know what the reason
you kind of piqued my interest is
because I have I've been aware of you
for a little while now because you do
you've got a YouTube channel you do
videos about property you inspire a lot
of people as well helping with their
mindset and different things I think you
mentioned grace to me yes he looks back
came on my attention and you mentioned
me a couple times in your videos and I
saw you kind of shouting me out and then
you even said I'm coming to the crash
course so I was like okay and then I saw
you at the crash course shouted you out
and then kindly you did a big long video
where you talked about your experience
at the crash course and you gave it like
a really beautiful I mean how much was
that yeah Lachie I was at the Samuel
this is the best testimony I think
you've ever had it was so good it was so
good that people thought that you'd been
paid by me
yeah that's crazy isn't it and I've got
loads of like comments saying have you
been paid and definitely not I went
there on my own accord and anyone that's
a subscriber of mine will know that I've
been to loads of seminars this year
already
so what I do is every time I go I say my
life as well I was actually like
thinking when I saw your video you put
Samuel Lee to crash course with you and
you actually had an angry face on the
thumbnail and that was some bad
something that was about something else
yeah because you've done videos in the
past where you've been to seminars and
you've kind of done like not exposed but
you've been like it was a bit I thought
it was just the best yeah yeah and
that's to give surprises that's right
and then it I think it was we spoke and
it was just like let's just get down to
the studio you do property videos yeah
why do you what made you won't stop in
videos on property investing and well
basically a few years ago I bought my
first home at like 26 and for me I've
always quite hard on myself so I sort of
it's a standard thing to do but I
realize a lot of people my age
like that first time so I thought why
don't I just tell people how to do this
motivate people and let people know how
to save money like efficiently and yeah
just smile for men then I get those a
question so they're not just your your
videos are detailed as well like they're
pretty specific videos helped by oh yeah
I've even robbed your idea yeah because
I have done that like when I was saving
for my home I had like 15,000 pounds
saved and I thought how the hell am I
gonna sell all this money so I tried the
government scheme and it was no use to
me so that is why I know about it at
first hand
yeah and so I just sort of like gave
everyone that ins and outs of it because
not everyone reads like the the details
there's a lot good few pages that I'm
sure people just think oh this is great
I can buy my first home but there's
there's pros and there's cons yeah yeah
started every year ago and I just I've
always wanted to do it always always
always and I'm always going to stop
myself so bit of a perfectionist but
like you're not you're young with your
YouTube videos might mean Emilia will do
a video together and I'll be like it's
just it's great and then I'll say let's
publish it and she'll say well let me
just go and just just polish it up a
little bit you just do it and it goes
out you don't even really have control
now because your give to the media team
that without you know I don't see the
videos or they go yeah see them I'm the
same as you I do about ten times and
make sure everything I say is right and
I do it in my videos like I don't miss
like I don't put things in it that is it
necessary to say yes oh yeah I get what
you mean so when you shoot a video like
this say it's a ten minute video how
long did you actually spend how much
content did you put out
No yeah what happened to the 30 minutes
I'm talking sometimes I say the same
thing in a different way and then I'm
not done at the way I said that so I'll
say again
yeah and then I use that bit did when
did you channel sort of start like I
noticed what as they blown up I just
mean went because you've got you've got
quite a lot of subscribers when did when
did that spike when did that happen
it's when I'm more consistent that's
when I know it's the gray from my
channel like I go through stages like a
few years ago where I don't post
anything like a month or two and then
yeah it's like you have to start from
scratch again so yeah you have to be
consistent your videos like you you've
just done a few ways you've done like a
trend or something yeah
oh it was about freshers it has a unique
yeah literally and it's I did him I
think things only needs you as well like
I did a video on my time in Australia
cuz I was left like a year I'd like us
to be abroad and that just picked up I
wasn't really any like magic behind know
what though YouTube is like having your
own TV show you do not need to be a
superstar to have a big YouTube channel
and I mean you even said like 15,000
views on some of your videos imagine if
you filled a room of 15,000 people
that's a lot nobody goes you know you
get a lot of views you go they've got a
lot of followers I know people always
saying you know do a meet-and-greet do
it ya know do you monetize off the back
of your channel at all do you do you do
you profit from it apart from just ads I
have been approached a few times for
like brands that want my there item on
my channel and stuff but I'm really
particular because obviously I don't
look like I'm selling something and it
has to like relate to what I'm talking
about and often I'm talking about like
motivational stuff so unless it's like
holistic or if it's and it's not often
that but sometimes I do like fashion
hauls you're not doing them
bikini [ __ ] I've got great bikini
that's the thing life sometimes people
might I'll do a video and help to buy
your doing video you have to buy but
people might resonate with unit
different way yeah yeah you know what's
your focus with your youtube channel my
focus I think has been consistent yeah
like that you're gay I did it where
those are bit where I was doing it every
week and it gave me so much fulfillment
cuz you just got you're on track your
life on track but I haven't posted for
ages and now I need to post yeah so
that's gonna wear my well as well cuz I
do like a bit of videography like I
started for someone as a videographer so
I think for me as well it's kind of that
thing of like I wouldn't feel
comfortable putting something up just on
my phone or something because people
know I've got that background be like
that's what it is yeah when I started my
youtube channel I just filmed everything
on my phone yeah when did you start I
did my first video at like five years
ago so I discovered your channel about a
year ago when I was looking for my
second home yeah and I literally just
tied something random and you came up
and and I literally learned a lot about
watching you and then I gave on that up
on that for a little bit but I still
mentioned you whenever anyone asked me
in my life chats but I just watched his
channel cuz he knows everything
yeah but you've been way more you post
every day you're already good as crazy
that's but then I've got five full time
videographers yeah and I don't edit the
videos myself I don't unless I sometimes
if we do a financial freedom challenge
or something on one edit myself just
because I'm a little bit like it's a I
know it's gonna get so many views dated
to how to edit the videos and I also as
well because my videographers follow me
around a lot so I'll have people on the
road of me follow me meetings it kind of
forces you to live an extremely
transparent life yeah
because I really feel like most people
there that one person when they're with
one group of friends another person when
they're with the family another person
when they're at work another person and
they have like carpark mentalize boxes
of how they live life
see I don't live like that but I
couldn't because if I did it'll be like
in my heart in my life into our business
there's no separation between business
between social between between church
between charity it's everything is just
my life and the same people cross over
and different people might say if I'm
with a certain group of friends they
might bring out something else in me
that others don't so it's not that
you're different I don't know yeah no
makes sense is weird I think that's a
way but then but then that would be a
different side but still you you still
being authentic and true yeah yeah I'm
still you know the definition of
integrity is doing in private what you
do in public yeah the definition of
integrity is is your values and
principles being the same you know you
know weak minded or blown by the wind so
having a different type of humor or you
know being serious and then be jokey it
like to be different around different
people because even for myself up into
like networking events even really
corporate and I'm Matt Grace
don't say you don't so just and I can't
help it so but some people can and they
can be different yes even on YouTube
people can be different yeah but also as
well when you got videographers fine you
and 24/7 you also can never lie yeah
imagine if I say something that's not
true
jeez I got video was filming me every
time so if I'm making a sale if I'm
trying to sell a piece of property or
whatever and I sell it and to get the
deal I'd say if it's not true I'm felt
yeah it takes a very transparent on his
person to allow someone to film in 24/7
yeah so - so what advice would you give
to people that want to be consistent
that don't have fire videographers I
said no you have to do things you really
enjoy doing like what I do is I write
down things that I want to talk about
and then like do a little a few bullet
points and you can even have one day I
shouldn't say this but I do it in like
one day I work full-time so I'm going to
do one day change my time when I have
one a week yeah you've got one for the
next five weeks
some people do one a day but like so
many people that work full-time to one
each weekend they could do a good few
yeah a video I don't tend to run that
long do they how long your video is
usually terminus yeah you don't need
loads of time to do and I think elbow we
do like hair and makeup so it's a bit
different as well like so many pictures
your brightness really well it's your
she'll talking about something but
she'll be putting makeup on makes you
want to watch it till the end
yeah I can't do that you know I love
watching my bangs my bangs
yeah well you watch people I know yeah I
know you don't want to just watch me no
honestly I love watching people it's a
bit weird but like do you watch Trisha
payors yeah yeah and she just sits there
she talks back any funny thing yeah just
eats and eats it's like a thing and
people watch you live and we will show
you what after this I'll check it out
you say that now but well you want you
to do that maybe you can work out and do
a video yeah once a day a workout
session okay
PJ he's so cool I mean honestly yes -
yeah yeah I went to one of his classes
the other day as well so I saw him in
his full potential
does people think because I have a
full-time personal trainer because he's
full-time because I hiring a full-time
payment full-time salary that he's
literally with me for so that kind of be
strange hmm so although he's with me a
lot he's not with me full-time sometimes
he'll do stuff Amelia or other people on
the team
yeah that's you at the gym doing like
training why is it just like he marvin
only comes from the house and literally
wakes you up what half sick wait wait no
he is my alarm clock then works Miette
then cooked me breakfast a good friend
so tell me tell me tell me when we met
and you first time we ever met with any
chemist yeah I was queuing up to talk CA
you were when what was the experience
like compared to what you thought it was
gonna be like I think I was waiting for
like a catch I've gotta say but I was
like this is great yeah
like honestly I loved it and everyone s
white she loved it as well and it really
like also you learn about prophecy and
stuff but it's also quite motivational
like that side of it is really really
valuable and you read the book the
secret didn't you yes I don't know
you've read the book the secret lots of
times
let's talk about it do you even have you
read the book the secret but I'm totally
familiar with all the principles I must
have read it like maybe a decade ago so
the law of attraction is like its energy
so everyone radiates energy good and
bars and so whatever you put out you
sort of get back so if you're positing
you think positively and you have like a
goal fair and you're hundred percent
certain about it it will happen I've no
doubt about that so so that's another
thing I want to say to you like with the
property thing like I can sit here and
tell you how to buy a property you could
sit there
tell all your your massive audience how
to buy property but if you don't have a
positive mindset it's actually I'm not
say it's not going to happen but it's
less likely to because if you're
positive everything aligns itself it
sounds crazy but yeah I see honestly
it's happened in everything in my life
me buy my home like 25 26 I had that as
a name when I was 18 don't anything I've
ever got in my life I thought about it
and I've got out you probably have
subconscious yeah I definitely believe
in the power the power of visualization
yeah yeah and also when you speak
something out I think you're speaking to
existence
yeah so I think you gotta be really
careful with your words yeah I never
speak I never speak negatively over
myself I'm not saying I'm not critical
of myself but but I'll never I'll never
talk down sorry I think a lot of humans
naturally we put ourselves down but yeah
I think when you're aware of it then you
don't do it in the beginning I was
always like I was like quite a negative
Sally and my like quite words don't have
high expectations because you'll always
be disappointed that was people so that
knows that obviously I'll never think
that now I'm like no it's all changed
I watched the secret when my mom's
friends actually boy around the house
and no one was paying attention to it
apart from me and then I'm like I think
I had lights when he planted my bank and
I spent $12.99 on the book and then from
then I swear like my whole life has
changed and I know that sounds crazy but
everything in my life I've ever wanted
happens
did you ever visualize the stuff that
you've got that it's weird cuz I don't
think everything I've visualized so to
speak Brown because you know sometimes I
like say if you wanted this flat it had
brown carpet you visualize every little
detail I think a lot for me was just
like energy that POW like for example
even me like working with you and here
it wasn't I was like rat and going to
see myself next time I do it but it was
although you did say something when we
first met
weird like yeah my um when we first met
so I don't have to sound like the crash
course was off thank you and our mum
came
with me as well and she was I even know
she was gonna say it's just weird
she told me beforehand you spoke
obviously yeah you know obviously we
won't speak about I was just like I want
to get into this like I'm super
confident about it like I'm gonna talk
to him and I'm um when she came up to
Samuel she was like and what sure she
was she'll surprise it you know and then
here we are like a year or so later and
I'm like with you every single day
and it's nothing it's because at that
point I would have never thought on
division I'm gonna be sung as a talent
manager but it was more just like like
without even thinking about it just my
whole energy about it even how the
opportunity came to me and I you saying
come down to London like when I think
about a lot of people like my friends
and people like that I just don't think
they detract the same opportunity what
attracted me about you was actually you
youtube channel yeah because you came to
the crash course do you think did some
advanced training you came on the deal
phonics olz human join the Academy which
was great but then oh I spot you on
YouTube and I saw YouTube videos and I
just thought and that to be honest
same with grace I wouldn't be saving
this conversation with grace if you
didn't have your YouTube channel yes you
just put yourself did you happen because
when someone's on YouTube sees people
say to me all the time
Samuel can have a coffee with you also I
wanted me I want to tell my story just
put it on YouTube and then I might see
it now everyone's happy opening YouTube
accounts but not only will I see it but
so everybody and then if you're a good
person you have good energy mm-hmm
they'll see that you've started doors
and stop it's crazy like even now that
what I'm talking about I'm like wow
we're not still done it but even the
tiny like few videos I did like like a
few videos my uni reached out some good
videos yeah even like my uni reached out
to me and wanting me to like speaking
for them and just from like videos out
doing like an hour in my bedroom at uni
like it's just crazy to me and it wasn't
even like consist at that point they're
just so like a warm video and was like
come and speak obviously Samuel
I even got offered other jobs that like
was seen through that so do you know
what having a YouTube channel is so much
more valuable in 22
that having a good CV yeah yesterday but
I don't know if I'd want my employer to
see my youtube channel really they will
see it sometimes already watched it no
I've never watched it because that we
planed um at least my channels like
quiet your chose good
it's not rubbish so that's good no I
mean it's not rush it
yeah I'm being like I'm putting out good
message it's not like I can't do
anything bad why would you not want them
to see it I just don't thinking worrying
and I've got I think some employers
worry that you've got a side hustle and
they might yeah worry about leaving or
something like that
and they don't think I'm focus on my
work cuz I'm focused on YouTube I don't
know that's an interesting because
what's the difference between just
having a personal brand and putting
yourself out there and trying to
influence people and then appearing to
just be distracted and unsatisfied like
I think it's a hard one as well because
obviously say if they knew that you had
your YouTube channel like they could be
like oh save you getting a bit
distracted work they could say it's that
but then everyone has that person I've
heard they're just they're just not
videoed it someone could be more not
focused
someone could be more focused by playing
PlayStation yeah I don't ever think is
all I believe how you do anything is how
you do everything
so if you're good or focused at YouTube
then you'll be good and focused it works
like see if I see my staff this is a
conflict of interest there's a conflict
of interest there's another thing by
having a YouTube channel and talking
about your experiences and sharing your
life of the world I don't see that as a
confident of interests so not any of my
staff don't want to have a youtube
channel I'll encourage them do some real
message me every week like you do it
yeah he did like super encouraging I was
gonna ask you actually you know if your
YouTube channel you've asked me this
where do you see it going do you think I
want to be a big youtuber your head no
for me it's kind of just like I think in
the minute YouTube for me is very much
just to get my own fulfillment I think
when you've wanted to do it like I
like way back like I'd watch YouTube
from like the beginning and I wanted to
do it from that so from me it's just
fulfillment like that tiny period of
time where I put a video up I've never
felt more fulfilled
you should I know it's just crazy and
it's just such a personal thing so then
it's annoying to me that's something so
not personalised off of me
I don't actually know that was the
reason but now it makes sense
yeah no it's completely fulfilling and
also I need that I need I bet I didn't
know that it was I didn't put the two
together though because you're a
professional videographer then you feel
like people would judge you because if
you put our video and it's not perfect
people aren't you specially videographer
but you know what number one on their
top wrong wrong deliberate misspelling
and then they know that everyone's going
to be like in the comment are you spell
this word oh I'm trying to be nice we're
trying to be critical is just gonna get
more comments which is gonna help the
algorithms yeah it's crazy so do it
enjoy it I know everyone oh yeah it
makes sense
it's just created like it is I feel that
personal branding like we talked about
personal branding so much but I feel
like it is just like an incredible thing
like you probably have like a lot of
brands reach out to you and that kind of
thing I should probably work with more
brands but I feel like I actually enjoy
just talking about what I want to talk
about but when I have to promote
something else on the eye you don't look
forward to it and also if people said
it's scripted there's no way you're that
feminine to give me that Emilia I think
I mentioned to you really came on the
podcast first time you came on the pod
and other questions oh I don't I don't
know why she was gonna ask me it was
that oh I bet Samuel gave Amelie at
those questions beforehand her stare
it's like are you serious like it's just
but then I thought people that like your
neighbors that are nosy it's like the
same speculate oh what's she doing
like I haven't got time I do a video
every day yeah I mean I fair place than
they want to speculate base not actually
helping them and I anyone that's
subscribed to me I would never recommend
them using their time that way I just
see things for what it is don't worry
and everybody be a youtuber youtuber I
think everybody should document document
what they do know because I think school
kids like you can't enjoy yourself
anymore you have to document your whole
life and it's like why don't you just
say if we have a chat I'm having a chat
now yeah if we document a whole day and
we're aware that I don't know it's just
you can't relax and enjoy yourself
obviously you've got videographers so
it's a bit different but a normal person
can have their phone and you'll stop
alright guys this you know it mean all
the time but I get what you mean it's
the way we're going now and most amazing
funny thing people say you know I've
seen these pictures of weather have like
cartoons have everyone just anti-social
but then if you look 60 years ago you
see the same picture on the bus and
everyone just reading a newspaper
ya know because a newspaper is telling
you what to think
whereas a phone you can actually serve
so I think that I actually am quite my
kids they'll be on the iPad and stuff
I'm happy for them to be on the iPad and
people say oh that's terrible
because if they want to be rich believe
me they're gonna need to know how to use
a computer yes
so for me to take that away from them so
their kids that shouldn't be on it as
long as they're not on it loads as long
as they
still enjoys balance but and I'm still
figuring this out I'm not saying my way
it's right but I think it's good be on
the phone phone is not antisocial
because I use I use my YouTube channel
to actually promote physical events yeah
so I bring people together I used the I
use the internet as a way to bring
people physically together who would
never get together if it wasn't for that
it depends how you're using it because
I've seen you even now you're not black
on your phone and not talking some
people will literally like you'll see a
group of friends and are not talking
they're just on their phone so it
depends yeah it's like you know just to
say you shouldn't like anything you're
interested I could be interested in
watches but then I could be obsessed and
that's true but that's the case I
suppose with everything in moderation
and the reason people are obsessed with
technology in phones and computers is
because they're so freakin good so good
you have the world in your hands you can
find out anything you need to know
online within reason very love Kay oh I
think it's the best time to be alive
yeah this is the best time if you want
to get rich like now you can you've got
so much opportunity you have it on your
phone
look listen like now in 2020 we have
cars so we can drive to properties to
view them we have planes if you want to
fly we have the Internet in our hands
there's just no excuses as to why we
just everything's there so I think it's
great yeah I get the whole balance thing
I think this definitely needs to be
balanced but I think I feel like
personal branding and filming yourself
and just putting yourself out there it's
just such a powerful thing yeah like you
must know the people like your father
walk into some rooms now I'll go to some
events and people just know who you are
and it's quite like humbling to know
that you could just walk into a room and
be like if you were doing business from
it so say if you were like property or
anything like that you can kind of get
deals and like people know who you are
before you even enter the
that's true you can use it like don't
get me wrong like it it can be an
amazing we're getting you a bit wrong
but I don't recommend every single
person to be like on it all the time
depends what you're doing that we
obviously do YouTube so we need to be on
it is why I say if people hate being on
camera I still suggest that they
document what they do it even if I tell
like my students who do improper jail I
said look if you can't be on camera
because you just hate that then at least
take pictures you do not to go on it you
mean like to inspire me not just to spy
people but also let's say you you're
buying said this job you know just do
the loads of really good property deals
for the last however many years right
she's on the economy and I've said to
her if you've got pictures in the
stories it's a case today so then if you
want a job that you people don't do
business with me because I know here's
my piece of portfolio it's a it's a it's
an entrepreneur's CV yeah my youtube
channel is an entrepreneur CV if you
want to get to know me you want to
figure out what I'm about
you're just the best of me you look at
my youtube channel you look on my social
media you see my pictures you see my
story you see my testimonials you'll see
and depending on how you want to see it
if you want to view through LinkedIn and
see a more professional version or if
you want to go to Instagram and see a
more fun
snappy version or YouTube again when we
dip version I am online people cannot
buy from you if they don't know who you
are yeah and people know who I am
because I put myself out there meaning
it's very easy for me to do business
with people so I walk into a stager and
they know the way I'm already it's very
easy for me to do a deal with them
because they know who I am
and and if and if someone doesn't like
me then they'd have got to know me and
watch me anyway so yeah yeah and it's
just something that's always there feel
like even when you sleep your YouTube
videos they're the object I feel
engaging but you're it's almost like
passive passively meeting people 7 hours
the average person will want to spend
seven hours a week before they do
business with you so you either have to
spend seven hours of people or have
seven hours worth of footage
I'll be watching seven hours of my face
yes so I say we brought in a book if you
brought a book someone reads the book
take some three hours to eat the book
they've spent three hours with you you
write it once and suddenly you've
impacted someone someone's got to know
you so it's how can you get what you
mean but you're like you're doing really
well when you are like really
informative they're not everyone here
not been mad for not every single person
is doing what you're doing so it just
depends what you're doing yeah and I
think you can always kind of use it even
if you were they can use it to your
advantage so you might not want to do
property but you might want to even if
you just did it's like build your
confidence or maybe want to tell someone
about your little side hustle or even
just like little things quiet self so to
assume I've done much but actually a
thousand interesting things has happened
to them probably saying against it is
that a lot of people especially
influences only show one side of their
life and that's why my channel I talk
about everything I don't know if you've
seen my other videos I only watch the
property you may watch the happy ones
but like ice why on my channel I'm very
real and I say look life isn't always
like playing sailing things happen and I
feel like a lot of influence there's no
shades to them obviously that's their
brand or whatever but I feel like people
watch them and think and why isn't my
life all like sunny and rosy all the
time and that's the only thing I think
that's the main critique I have a bit
that if everyone's really real
like you are real but other people like
oh yeah things always good you said a
video that I'm the only youtuber that
you watch you're the only yeah you're
the only do to buy watch and yeah that
consistently that's a compliment yeah
the channel cuz I don't really spend a
lot of my time like on watching you to
be honest but yeah but when you do your
what you mean yeah what did you like
about the channel it's really
informative and you're like very
enthusiastic to the point and you have
lots of like different videos so then I
don't have to like what you write I
guess I can guess who I want to say
you just say what you won you don't just
yeah apply too much dough yeah it's the
very direct so it's good yeah you helped
me lots of people and you've got good
Testament like those eyes of people
saying they become financially for you
from watching your video say every week
yeah and what's your what's your goal
with YouTube and that's the thing I
actually don't have one and when you
asked me that the other day I actually
need to actually have one because I
always help people you need to have an
aim need to know where you going I am
with every other part of my life but
with YouTube I just see it as oh it's
something I enjoy doing I like helping
people but maybe I need to see it more
in a business way perhaps I have seen on
like courses to learn about you should
oh yeah yeah I've been on one how was it
it was good it was a guy called Derral
Eve's you may have heard of him and yeah
he was just saying about the algorithm
about collaborating I also say it was
last year so this is a collab yeah this
is a collab collab yeah he said to
collaborate with other youtubers or even
like mention someone how does this cool
about them so this this collab we're
doing the three of us like how what from
someone who's a youtuber someone who's
wanting to meet you all understand
collab so how does it come about and
what's the what's the craic what you
mean like how do you approach people
well how does it work see just because
because I think probably different
youtubers have got different I don't
even understand the etiquette probably I
mean it is all that stuff but but like
from my perspective I don't care about
when I don't get people on my channel if
I'm going over the peoples channel I
don't really care about how many
subscribers or views they yeah I don't
care about any of that stuff all I care
about is do a lot at them and what
they're gonna be able to provide insight
to my to my guys know it's the thing is
you can collaborate with anyone but a
lot of youtubers only when I collaborate
with someone in their calibre sort of
thing was which subscribers yeah so it's
hard for like smaller youtubers so then
because they know you know you haven't
got enough sort of thing do you know
what that's good because because we do
get approached a lot but people want to
do co.labs and do things and
if it was my if I had it my way I would
just say yes to everybody I think if you
if you listening to this and you've been
you've been talking why are you looking
for Milly when you're looking for :
partners or people to do stuff with get
on the channel yeah like what are you
looking for value life someone can bring
value if someone's got unique
perspective if someone's got a cool
story I think I don't want to just watch
myself
yeah just really like if I know
someone's channel I I did the other day
I went on yeah I don't have any
subscribers she's got I guess what I get
he's a friend I would other chap Marcus
de Maria that's crazy
any so Marcus came round and he
interviewed me and he's got a channel
about stocks and shares okay so that's
his thing now he's interviewed me on his
channel number one I am NOT gonna poopoo
stops and shares on this channel and try
and go should you probably instead
because that would be I would see that
as me being a dick so instead when I'm
talking to given analogies I'm actually
talking in terms of stocks a bit and of
course I'm bringing a bit about talking
about property but I'm not trying to I'm
not trying to get his subscribers change
daily secondly I'm respectful of him
because it's his channel so I'm gonna be
timing to be you know I'm gonna be big
in him up I'm gonna be a he I took I
just to say yes because clearly I like
him and its general solving to say that
I'm gonna talk about how he's helped me
I would talk about me so just being
respectful I'm not gonna sound I'm gonna
be trying to talk about you know if you
want to eventually a message me or
trying to be Steven so I'm just there to
give for how you did it can be subscribe
and when people come on my channel I
expect the same same story tell us what
about you do you ever collab and if so
what you people have approached me about
a collab but for me there nothing not
saying nothing like me they'll say oh I
have similar content to you and that's
one thing I'd say if they have similar
content or you can relate to each other
because you could have someone sitting
here and they could only do that makeup
videos which I love makeup don't get me
wrong but I have to we have to have a
rapport and also I have you have to be
valuable to my audio
- like I'm just gonna have someone there
there's some brand and person approaches
to be honest most time you're the first
one I said yes I'll tell you the point
of my youtube channel wall Amelia six
deep within a soul I was just gonna say
about when people are like save someone
was really plugging themselves on camera
I'm kind of like the whole point of a
collab is like you'll be or national
they might be on yours that kind of
thing and you're gonna get people go to
channel naturally if you give don't
necessarily need to like kind of look
yourself okay here's my points and I'd
love to know what you think of these
points okay number one anybody can be
financially free
anybody that has a mental positive
attitude and it's hard working yes
financially free yeah okay um next you
can buy property starting with nothing
from watching you of course yeah you can
good debt is really good yeah
I've got good debt yeah because some
people say that's bad no it's not
education is the best investment yes
knowledge is power always the more you
know I always say the more you know the
more you yeah
property investing is easy I haven't
done it yeah no but I bought a home and
yeah it's easier than people think
you know I say that you know what says
easy that gets to stick for this cuz
it's really hard it's no harder than
anything else
listen property investing people make it
so complicated it's actually not that
complicated
yes of it's like driving yeah I'm saying
I'm not so if I say driving if I'm your
driving instructor and you get in the
less and you try can interview first
listen I go by the way this is really
hard
yeah can be really difficult what I'll
do is I'm disempowering the person if I
say listen this is very easy of course
you can omit the lessons but you did
this is there's not much to this and
you're gonna get it it's going to become
second nature it's the same thing yes
it's hard if you don't know what you're
doing and you're gonna get yourself in a
pickle and yes it's gonna take hard work
yeah
so that's my point qualifications are
overrated yeah they are namely a YouTube
channels more vapor than a CV yeah I
agree that experience is more valuable
yeah
the system wants you to be poor yes the
government no just the government well
we it works in people's favor of people
I think the guy that government scheme
that I spoke about and you spoke about
to help to buy one yeah that doesn't
allow you to buy another home to buy a
second home no because I don't want you
to and I wants to money government after
what the whole system I'm talking about
I'm talking about the education system
I'm talking about the banks I'm talking
about super-rich the elite again about
the government I'm talking about the
media you look money but they don't
teach you how to make money at school
they teach show you the way you make
money is you have to go and get a job
yeah yeah the traditional way and the
last one is you you create your own life
yes you are responsible for everything
in your life that is just there yeah
that's my message no it's true and and
everything I talk about falls down to
that no it's a hundred saintil green I
think often we have this like blame
culture in the UK that we have to blame
everyone for everything like our
failures or oh wait that happened
because of this but if everyone just
took accountability for their like
actions and not even the mistakes I've
made it's been my fault
so you learned for me right you learn
from your mistakes and then you got you
fail your way to success you made any
mistakes of course I made mistakes
yeah I wouldn't look back at my life and
say I've got regrets okay your mistakes
make you they're not even mistakes but
okay if I bring up an agent and try and
negotiate to buy property and they say
no that's cute like how dare you be so
rude to put the phone down at me that's
a failure well no I aren't my objective
was for me to make the call and get a
win yeah and I didn't so I failed in the
same way if I shoot
the board you're going the in the
targeted misses yeah get some know
sometimes I hold the shot but I'm not
gonna fail the game okay that that cool
right there failed and in that point I
can choose to say what am i a failure
hmm you can give up in property
investing no no did that call fail yes
yeah yeah so I think probably have a lot
have had a lot of failure yet what you
are yeah I have I've had a lot of you a
little I feel that I've made a lot of
mistakes I've had a lot knows but I've
also had more wins and more yeses than
anyone I think a lot of people like if
they get a knock back that sort of knock
stand properly back whereas someone like
you would be alright that's happened how
can I learn from this
let's keep going mmm so if you have that
sort of mentality
yeah grace no I am gonna buy it
I'm gonna look in two weeks
okay show me deposit saved I've got my
equity are you bothering me yeah yes so
cool cuz you've known about it forever
last year I was gonna do it and then
nationwide didn't let me take equity out
but I know how to get around that but
yeah but it's yeah and I felt like I
wasn't in the right place mentally and I
worked on my I always believed that you
have to be mentally prepared for
everything and now I am and I know what
I want to do a hundred percent yeah and
there was other things as well am I
going to politically of like yeah it's
there yes Brett said yeah and also with
something else as well like say if I
safe labor got involved yeah I think
they would have given more right listen
baby worried about talking about this
stuff okay
to talk on the Java stuff I saw Labour's
manifesto manifesto
I saw what Jeremy Corbyn was saying yeah
he was what he was saying he was gonna
do people were absolutely putting
themselves yeah scared like crazy
guess what I was doing I was buying of
course because obviously their prices
leather because everyone was so scared
yeah yeah it was my buying I was also
100% confident that Labour would not
okay I was so confident at 9:00 listen I
was so confident in a YouTube video
about it right yeah I'm gonna hold off
because I later what do you think I said
I'll give you take back man you know you
can give you tell me a favor charge I
can take run this again okay yeah yeah
so I did it because everyone on my face
because ya know like proper names was so
good and then is usually I listen yeah
I've got very good friends who even I
wouldn't even say on this point that
point I believe that you create your own
yeah kind of saying I believe you create
your own economy however sometimes some
of the far left wings liberal people
liberal people they tend to be a lot
more vocal ships yes that is true
missing the great yeah you'll missing
with my hair did I mess with your head
of the crash course yeah I think you
know I was like really mentally tired I
think I couldn't sleep for two days head
is just ticking over yeah I think I'm
like now it's settled
I just felt like supermoto idea and a
lot of people as well cuz you've been in
a room for two days with everyone that
you know now on the same level like
energy-wise never get and they leave and
you all go home when you're just kind of
like at home like you know it's just
kind of crazy so I think I was
definitely like switched on for a few
days after kind of like just still
motivated for it yeah do you kind of
feel when you leave an environment like
that because I'm growing a lot training
programs also
tend to our training programs yeah I get
to it I'm I've spent millions of helps
on going on courses and because saw it
in the last few years
yeah book in a minute the minute he's
already like paid for enough that with
them like grant cardone and tough like
wanted up training yeah I'll see you
guys some more one on one training than
like no I do you rooms as well I got all
sorts would you we do you mean to do
better what business coaches yeah
strategic planning and it's not cheap
it's expensive but they never told my
invest in my own training I know I'm
growing as a person
that's yourself yeah yeah can't beat
that
yeah and that means when you're selling
treatment as well like it'd be kind of
hypocritical of you to sell training but
then never train yourself well it would
be intense everything you would it would
go grain against my soul core being so
for me not to just because I believe in
the reason I the reason I teach people
is because I believe in do is have a
training companies good I believe in
training yeah Alicia not I know it all
that things you don't need to know
anything else I've even learned from my
students there's even this youtuber that
does property videos to buy stuff I know
it's good knowledge is power always and
the more you learn about I'm always
teaching myself as well what inspires
you why don't you talk about property so
much on your channel because I'm a young
even yeah sure on my channel I talk
about the normal way so like buying your
most people just want to buy a home like
to live in and I talk about that because
a lot of people say it helps I've
actually got like sent pictures of keys
people bought homes because of watching
my videos and stuff and I give them
belief and even my friends like to my
girl might support houses and they
always say if you weren't my friend I
would've bought my house so so it's like
giving yourself belief that you can do
this and then you do it so I haven't
gone on that route on my channel about
the
yeah I have spoken about I'm gonna do
that and but yeah I try and focus on
like your mind more than anything
because I think as well like you reach
you've researched stuff for yourself
yeah and then you've just shared is that
powerful because a lot of people won't
reflect like you were saying before that
people won't read the fine print and
whether you like packaging I'm a gank
yeah I don't look like one but I do I do
read a lot and I if I I'm gonna do
something I want to know everything
about it before I do it one was the very
first youtube video they did I did a
makeup one Barney because my friends
kept telling me to do it no man was just
a I've wanted to do YouTube for six
years introduction so I think it's cool
to see like people doing more
interesting concert like my first
youtube video was if I remember was me
just going round the house to look at to
buy and I just thought oh video so not
make did you did you set up out to be
Asian or you just did it when did you
want to guess it what made you want to
become serious with YouTube the
evergreen dose of YouTube okay your
videos are very evergreen yes but but a
and no other platform on social media we
still have agreed so if I it's almost
like a library so if someone says to me
Samuel can you teach oh I need to know
I've got a question it will probably be
in my YouTube channel and if it's not
then I'll need to do what do you ever
worry that you're gonna run out of video
ideas no you know what because their
property everything's changing as well
yeah yeah so things are changing rules
change in and every time I guess I get
hundreds of people messaging me asking
me questions about property so there's
always something new or something I'm
ready to throw up
yeah and even you go to different
countries now that you went to America
and there's enough I've challenged so
you like different market Sabri yeah
interesting and which will be looking
into more what do you want to see how my
youtube channel in 2020 what you're
doing yeah what do you want to see
what's your favorite kind of video what
do you think of dirt under your videos
and also like documentaries very
interested the one video that like
sticks out to you other than maybe an FF
challenge well I I'm really interested
in the H of my own videos because
obviously they are yeah I've watched a
lot of them I can't remember lies but I
like the one where of Glenn yes yeah
that was really good that could have
been on TV oh yeah that was good yeah
that was good my favorite video of you
was definitely the one where you talked
about me anyone who was watching you
when you came in as well yeah she was do
my due diligence baby you just doing
some research on me yeah so I looked at
me you guys I'm cheering you on my
youtube channel I think I think you're
gonna blow blow blow
yeah I think so it's just fresh content
as well I think your channel has a lot
of content that a lot of people aren't
going out there thank you yeah well your
China is definitely gonna blow much
already already blown and it's gonna go
isn't that it's already blown a little
bit it's kind of like like a like a like
a but a because I think when I started
watching you was like he had a 60,000
and I was like a year ago
so ready no not even that maybe
thousands or no yeah probably a year ago
maybe 40,000 yes so he's done any well
yeah but now he's breathing but no I'll
keep what you have interests and the
properties are things I'm looking
forward to seeing you're killing it yeah
I still trying to persuade those join
the Academy
I'll be honor I'll be honor I'll be on
it when the cameras are off did you find
how selling was the crash course how did
you feel all right
it's my way that's what some people
think think no I know because I was
expecting but I've been to I was
seminars in there way more way we just
made a short offer and the thing is it's
normal - I think so your course yes I
should be a charity yes
like we just make like a 15 minute mmm
hey this is the program yeah I don't
think it's any old I don't know why
people say that I just think you know
what people that that sensitive to being
sold to I'll say something controversial
now people that are that sensitive that
they feel like a 15 minute little short
offer yeah he's like oh my gosh I was
sold to and it's terrible it's the words
that have happened to me they will never
be able to sell
yeah helps because they're so sensitive
about this whole topic of means of sales
they'll never be able to sell yeah if
you will never be able to sell you're
never gonna make any money
yeah it's true because mmm sales equals
income so if you come to the crash
course and you're so upset by a
15-minute offer in a 14 hour day then
it's probably should knock out to be an
entrepreneur astray and also I think
people say well because you naturally
have enthusiasm and so do all your
speakers so imagine if you was like I'm
gonna so see you now and all of a sudden
your society yeah we've got this course
and it's free but I think because you're
if you see a stick I know they're trying
to sell us something but that's how you
are so I think people don't correlate
that on don't quite understand that
obviously you're an enthusiastic person
you have to sell something you're not
gonna be like depressed fail it's
anything at all yeah and I know for
speaking to you you're you actually you
obviously really believe in your course
and you want me to go in it because you
know it's gonna help me it's not because
you just want to make money from me and
I can tell that so
so no I know and I'm taught by lots of
people suppose you don't change your
Marquette what are you only because we
can to wealthy be very well advised a
lot only caters people that you know
have a certain amount of money maybe
celebrities only this person only but
because we could just do a lot with them
but the thing is I'm a working-class guy
I grew up at times knowing what it's
like to drive anything an amazing
education less for 16 so I want to help
people
yeah yeah I don't want to just work with
only people that have got 250 grand
qualified investors yeah because that's
not because you'd be criticized if you
did that as well so either way you can't
win I think because then it would be
just a case of all you know he works
with people ya know the highest is
ultimately no you know I get a lot of
satisfaction from one day and I know
some people might say oh sorry but like
I've got thick enough skin
to know that actually we're helping so
many people today just energy energy is
amazing at the economy because that's
everybody it's a whole new level and the
amount of people in the room the economy
events that killing it doing do fight
you for it it's just it's quite surreal
if there was like Samuel eat property
paradise which will be probably it's
like when do you ever have a room with
people where most of the people there
are financially free doing daily being
in that environment the positive peer
pressure in the property paradise room
is just second to none
and how can you not be successful when
you personally know so many people that
are financially free it just rubs off
yeah no you're right it does you can't
get that from
try it yeah it just pops off and I think
in person you'll learn way more anyway
we should do a program called do it off
no seminars yeah yeah didn't have to go
so hey did you busy jumping up making
phones coordinators running around doing
things so now that's awesome
if we can help you in any way let us
know we'll need to give you and we'll
leave a link in the description to your
great space yeah thank you for having me
[Music]
[Music]